Oh
hi, ich bin Katie Radisson, willkommen zurück bei den
Denkerinnen und der Antike und dem
Mittelalter, die Ihnen vom King's
College präsentiert werden.
Der Eunuch heute wird die
dritte Vorlesung sein, in der wir uns
mit Frauen in der späteren antiken Philosophie und
insbesondere in beschäftigen werden  Spätantike, also lassen Sie mich
ein wenig darüber sagen, was das bedeutet, dass
die Antike ein Ausdruck ist, den Gelehrte
jetzt verwenden, um sich besonders auf die Antike zu beziehen,
die ziemlich weit in die
Geschichte hineinreicht, so wie nach dem Fall der
Römischen Republik vielleicht und ich bin  Meistens
wird über Figuren aus
dieser Zeit gesprochen werden, auch am Anfang
werden Figuren aus
hellenistischer Zeit berührt und es hilft vielleicht ein
wenig, wenn ich gleich
zu Beginn den Unterschied zwischen
klassischer Antike, hellenistischer Zeit
und Spätantike besonders mit aufzähle
Bezug auf die Geschichte der Philosophie, da
wir hauptsächlich darüber sprechen,
also hat in diesem Baum der Philosophieklassengrenzen
die klassische Antike im Grunde
die Vor-Soziologie  Rattenperiode, also beginnen alle
Denker bis hin zu Sokrates als
Platon und Aristoteles, und das ist im Grunde das,
was wir bisher behandelt haben, also haben wir
uns einige Finger angesehen, die diese
angeblichen Pythagoräer waren, und dann haben wir
uns die Ansichten von Plato und
Aristoteles angesehen und wir haben gesehen  dass Platon im Großen
und Ganzen das ist, was man einen
feministischen oder relativ feministischen Denker nennen könnte,
zumindest denkt er, dass Frauen
Philosophie betreiben
können und
sollten  Sie müssen keine Philosophen sein, und in der Tat, wenn
Sie sich die Geschichte ansehen
, so spielen sich die Dinge ziemlich genau ab, also gibt es keine
weiblichen Philosophen in der aristotelischen
Tradition, es gibt in der Ära, die
platonische Tradition sein kann, aber bevor
wir damit anfangen, müssen wir tun  Mit
der hellenistischen Zeit wird die
hellenistische Zeit oft als die
Zeit zwischen den Eroberungen Alexanders
des Großen
und irgendwo im ersten Jahrhundert bezeichnet  BC
vielleicht oder sogar im ersten Jahrhundert n. Chr. Es ist eine
defensive Frage, aber man könnte vielleicht sagen,
dass ein Patrick definitiv eine
nette Art von Marker wäre und der Aufstieg von
Augustus Caesars, also werden wir den Übergang
von der Römischen Republik zum Römischen
Reich
nicht bekommen  zu sehr daran interessiert, dass der Hauptunterschied, der
uns interessiert, darin besteht,
was in der Geschichte der
Philosophie in dieser Zeit vor sich geht, also in der
hellenistischen Zeit, also grob gesagt,
sprechen wir jetzt eigentlich
eher von der Zeit des vierten Jahrhunderts v
Platon ein Aerosol, also haben wir von dort
bis vielleicht zum zweiten oder dritten
Jahrhundert n. Chr. die Ausbreitung
mehrerer philosophischer Schulen und diese
Schulen haben Namen, die Ihnen bekannt sein werden,
also haben wir die Stoiker, wir haben die
Epikureer, wir haben die  Zyniker und wir
haben diese Skeptiker bemerkt, dass
es im Englischen immer noch all diese Wörter gibt,
dass Sie stoisch über ein
Problem sein können, mit dem Sie konfrontiert sind, Sie können ein
Genießer sein, was Ihre Essgewohnheiten
angeht, Sie können cy sein  Wenn man über
Erfolgsaussichten oder über Politik skeptisch ist und man bei allem skeptisch sein kann,
ist hier eine interessante Frage,
inwieweit Frauen an diesen Schulen eine Rolle gespielt haben
, und ich werde gleich darauf zurückkommen,
aber lassen Sie mich zuerst  Sagen Sie, was
wir mit Spätantike oder spätantiker Philosophie meinen,
also können Sie
die Grenze zwischen der hellenistischen Zeit und der Spätantike überall dort markieren,
wo Sie wollen,
aber ich würde eher
um das 3. Jahrhundert n. Chr. Zeichnen, es ist nett  In
letzter Zeit und der Grund dafür ist, dass
der Thymus der
Begründer einer neuen Art der Philosophie ist,
die wir jetzt Neuplatonismus nennen. Er
hätte sich nicht als Neuplatoniker bezeichnet, sondern
nur
als Platanus und im Grunde als der
Der Name impliziert, dass er ein Anhänger Platons ist,
aber er übernimmt viele Ideen von
anderen Schöpfern,
insbesondere vom Stoizismus und
Aristotelismus, und dies ist eine sehr
erfolgreiche Form der Philosophie, so m  uch so
dass alle
anderen Schulen effektiv ausgerottet werden, es schluckt Ideen von
ihnen und jeder als Wort, am
deutlichsten ab dem dritten Jahrhundert mit
wenigen Ausnahmen unter den Heiden und ungefähr
zur gleichen Zeit haben Sie natürlich den
Aufstieg des Christentums in der Spätantike
und  Für eine Weile existieren heidnische und
Platons Philosophie neben der
christlichen Philosophie, und die beiden sind in
gewisser Weise Rivalen, so dass einige heidnische
Philosophen sich
vom Christentum sehr bedroht fühlen. Fast alle
christlichen Philosophen waren sehr
kritisch gegenüber heidnischen Philosophen,
aber wir sollten sie trotzdem als
zwei betrachten  Stränge der Philosophie und nicht
in die übliche Falle zu tappen, zu denken, dass
es christliche Theologen und heidnische
Philosophen gibt, also wäre die Fatah, wir
wären zum Beispiel ein Philosoph, aber
Agustin würde das nicht tun. Ich würde
Agustin und zahlreiche andere christliche
Denker als Philosophen betrachten, und es
geht nur weiter  um eine Rolle in der Geschichte zu spielen,
werde ich ihm diesen Vortrag so bei
thi erzählen  s Zeit, besonders wenn das Christentum
wirklich in Gang kommt, da der Kaiser
mit Konstantin beginnt, wir haben auch die Zeit des
christlichen Kaisers, so dass
Sie politische Unterstützung für das Christentum
haben könnten, und Sie haben diese beiden philosophischen
Traditionen nebeneinander, aber
in vielerlei Hinsicht und für unsere Zwecke
So ziemlich alle relevanten Arten, wie
sich herausstellt, dass die christliche und die heidnische
Philosophie und die Antike sehr
ähnlich sind, so dass sie beide den Platonismus und den
Stoizismus der Throne gezeichnet haben, und wie wir
gleich sehen werden, dachten die Stoiker auch,
dass Frauen Philosophen sein könnten, also ist es
vielleicht keine  Überraschend ist, dass Sie eine
große Veränderung zwischen der klassischen Antike, die
wir bisher betrachtet haben, und der
Spätantike, die bereits in gewissem Maße
hellenistisch war, in der hellenistischen Zeit erleben, und
die große Veränderung besteht darin, dass wir jetzt sehr
klar benannte Frauen haben, in denen die
Philosophen dieses Etwas bereits
erwähnt haben  Die erste Vorlesung, das ist
aufregend, und darüber werden wir
in dieser Vorlesung sprechen, aber es gibt eine
Wichtige Einschränkung, um etwas anderes zu bedenken, das
ich in der ersten Vorlesung erwähnt habe,
nämlich die Philosophinnen, von denen wir
wissen, dass sie keine Werke geschrieben haben,
die uns heute erhalten sind,
also würden einige der Leute
über Hypatia Macrina monica
sprechen, das sind die drei  Leute, über die
ich hauptsächlich sprechen werde Hypatia ist eine
berühmte heidnische Philosophin, die
von einer christlichen Mutter in Alexandria
hingerichtet wurde
Christian und sie ist die
Brooke, die Schwester von Gregor von Nyssa,
und er schrieb Werke über sie, da
wir sehen werden, dass Monica die Mutter von
Agustin ist, und er schrieb Werke, in denen
sie erwähnt wurde, und Sie werden feststellen, dass
wir dies in allen drei Fällen nicht tun  Haben Sie tatsächlich irgendwelche Texte,
wenn Sie sie kaufen, zumindest nicht
zu philosophischen Themen, wir haben einige
Beweise für Hypatias Arbeit in
Mathematik, also gibt es
hier gute und schlechte Nachrichten. Die guten Nachrichten sind wir
definitiv  haben wie wirklich existierende
Philosophen, die Frauen sind, also müssen wir
nicht kommen, zum Beispiel eine Gottheit MA aus
Platons Symposium, wo wir nicht einmal
sicher sind, ob sie echt war, wenn sie
echt war, sind wir uns nicht sicher, ob das, was Platon
sagt und sagt  in ihrem Mund als alles, was
sie wirklich gesagt hätte, oder die
pythagoreischen Briefe, die wir gesehen haben,
wurden Jahrhunderte nach der Annahme geschrieben, dass
Autoren tatsächlich gelebt haben
, haben wir dieses Problem nicht, aber wir haben ein neues Problem, nämlich, dass wir
sogar die
Werke seiner Frauen lesen  wir haben
sozusagen nur Werke von Männern gelesen
, was wir lesen, sind sehr positive
Berichte von Männern über
Frauen, also ist das offensichtlich kein Grund
zu sagen, wir sollten es nicht ernst
nehmen und den Dienst annehmen  und
es ist ein Vortrag, aber es ist ein Grund zu
erkennen, dass er warten
muss, um Werke zu lesen, die
tatsächlich von Frauen geschrieben wurden und heute überlebt haben. Okay,
also lass uns jetzt zu dem zurückkehren, was ich gerade
über die hellenistische Zeit gesagt habe
Wir haben diese Schulen, die Stoiker,
die Epikuräer, die Zyniker und die
Skeptiker. Was Sie vielleicht bemerken, ist,
dass ich den Platonismus nicht erwähnt habe und
es dort eine chilenische ISM gab, also ist es
nicht so, dass sechs Schulen
in der hellenistischen Zeit um die Vorherrschaft
kämpften, obwohl  Das
Schlimmste von Platon und Aristoteles war
sicherlich bis zu einem gewissen Grad bekannt. Es gibt
tatsächlich einige Debatten darüber, wie viel
Ausmaß, aber obwohl sie bekannt
waren, waren sie nicht sehr einflussreich, und Sie
haben keine starke Tradition des
Platonismus, wie wir ihn oder Aristoteles verstehen würden
In dieser Zeit
erlebten sie ein Comeback um das erste
zweite Jahrhundert n. Chr., bis Sie mit dem
Thymus den Aufstieg des Neuplatonismus und
den endgültigen Sieg des Platonismus über
die anderen Schulen haben, bevor
wir diese anderen Schulen haben, die
in gewisser Weise wir sind  auf Plato und Aristoteles reagieren, sie
aber nicht
unbedingt als Hauptaugenmerk auf beide Figuren nehmen
, im Gegenteil, sie haben ihr eigenes
philosophisches Fou  Es ist so offensichtlich, dass die
Epikureer auf Epikur
zurückblicken, die Zyniker auf Diogenes, den zynischen
berühmten Philosophen, zurückblicken, aber es gibt viele
großartige Geschichten, und die berühmteste ist, dass
er sich auf seinem Weinkrug sonnt, in
dem er lebt, als König Alexander der
Große kommt und sagt  Was kann ich für
dich tun und ausweichen? Er sagt, du kannst aufhören
, mein Licht zu blockieren. Das ist eine berühmte
Geschichte über das Ausweichen. Es gibt einige
andere gute Geschichten über ihn. Er ist also der
Begründer des Zynismus. Ursprünglich
der Zynismus der Verteidigung
und
Sie kennen den Gründer des Stoizismus,
und die Schulen würden auf sie
als Gründerfiguren zurückblicken, die viel
Autorität haben. Eine Sache, die
hier erwähnenswert ist, ist, dass sich der Skeptizismus in
dieser Zeit weitgehend
innerhalb der platonischen Tradition entfaltet
weil Platons Akademie
von Skeptikern übernommen wurde, also sind sie kein Platanus in
dem Sinne, dass wir erkennen würden, dass sie
sich als Anhänger des Sokrates sehen
der in den platonischen
Dialogen dargestellt wurde, der immer
Fragen stellte, sich nie mit den Antworten zufrieden gab
, das ist ein Skeptiker in der
hellenistischen Canali-Mystikzeit,
das ist für uns so wichtig, weil
unter den Schulen tatsächlich die besten Beweise für
die Philosophie der Fraueninitiative
gefunden werden  Dieser lange Satz und die
Stoiker, also diese beiden Schulen,
besonders zu Beginn des Stoizismus
und während der gesamten Geschichte des
Zynismus, werden sie von anderen
Menschen und von sich selbst als in gewisser
Weise als asozial oder sehr
gesellschaftskritisch angesehen, was Sie besonders
sehen können  Das mit Diogenes, dem Zyniker, also diese
Idee, dass er in einem Weinkrug lebt, dass er
den Stock beleidigt, oder andere Geschichten über
ihn, die ihn im Grunde dazu bringen, sich
über Leute lustig zu machen, die andere Dinge tun, um zu
zeigen, dass er die Gesellschaft ablehnt, eines meiner
Lieblingsbeispiele dafür  ist, dass er damit
gewartet hat, bis eine
Theateraufführung auslief und dann Hunderte von
Menschen das Theater verließen  r er ging
hinein, das ist eine andere Geschichte über Genies,
die irgendwie zeigt, dass er denkt, dass
alle anderen falsch denken, wie
es das darstellen soll, aber
ich würde nicht sagen, dass in der Geschichte des
Zynismus viele Frauen vorkommen, aber
es gibt eine  Ein sehr berühmtes Beispiel gibt es
eine indische Partei Etta, die ein Senatsphilosoph war
und mit einem
anderen zynischen Philosophen verheiratet war, der im
Grunde das Objekt ihrer
Gesänge war und versuchte, sie davon zu überzeugen, dass
er nichts für ihn sei, indem er sich nackt auszog
und sagte, dies sei alles, was ich habe
Ihnen anzubieten, und sie sagte, ich nehme es im Grunde an,
und so heirateten sie und sie lebten
als Zyniker, also waren sie normal im Senat,
sie waren obdachlos, sie hatten Sex in der
Öffentlichkeit
usw. usw. und wieder ist sie nicht jemand,
für den wir überlebende Werke haben
Tatsächlich haben wir keine Werke von einem der
frühen Zyniker, also gibt es keine
Abhandlungen von Diogenes zum Beispiel, es
gibt nur Geschichten über ihn, wie die
Geschichten, die ich gerade erwähnt habe, aber es
gibt viele Anekdos  tes über den ersten
Satz und es gibt einen tollen Hund über
ihre Party, den ich gerne mit Ihnen teilen möchte,
also hier ist es, ich werde den Text
aufhängen, also ist sie wahrscheinlich auf einer Dinnerparty
und sie spricht mit diesem Typen in
Theodorus, der auch ist  ein Philosoph und
am Anfang der Geschichte, wie Sie
hier sehen können, heißt es, dass
Theodore als Atheist bekannt ist und sie sich
über einander lustig machen, und sie macht ihn nieder
, beleidigt ihn also, indem sie
dem Sophismus mit anderen Worten folgt  Von
zweifelhaften oder kniffligen Argumenten sagt sie, dass jede
Handlung, die nicht als falsch bezeichnet werden würde, die
ich von Theodorus getan habe, nicht
als falsch bezeichnet würde, wird von Hipparchus getan, jetzt
tut Theodorus nichts falsch, wenn er sich
selbst schlägt, daher tut auch eine
Partei nichts falsch, wenn sie  schlägt ihn und ich
schätze, wir müssen uns vorstellen, dass er/sie
ihn in diesem Stadium schlägt, er hatte keine
Antwort, versuchte aber, ihr ihren
Umhang auszuziehen, sie zeigte keine Anzeichen von Alarm oder
Panik wie eine Frau,
und als er sagte, ist das, dass sie aufhört,
Wolf und  Worf  kann kämmen und weben, das ist ein
Zitat aus dem Gedicht, auf das sie antwortete, er
wünsche Theodorus, aber denkst du, ich
habe mir selbst einen schlechten Rat gegeben, wenn ich,
anstatt Zeit am Webstuhl zu verschwenden, sie
für Bildung aufgewendet habe, eine wirklich interessante
Geschichte erzählt habe, weil sie tatsächlich zeigt, dass sie
ablehnt  die Standarderwartungen an
Frauen in der Antike in der Antike also, wenn Sie darüber
nachdenken, kennen Sie die
Annahme von Aristoteles, dass die Frau zu
Hause den Haushalt führen würde
, auf der Toilette arbeiten
würde, mit anderen Worten, das Weben wäre eine, wenn nicht
die paradigmatische weibliche Tätigkeit, so die
Tatsache  dass sie sagt gut ich webe nicht
ich verbringe meine ganze Zeit damit
Bildung zu erlangen sie ist kein Rekord da ist
Paideia
sie ist ein Spruch dass sie die
Erwartungen der Gesellschaft ablehnt die besonders
Geduld dass die Gesellschaft eine / hat eine
Frau damit sie als leben kann
Philosoph, und das passt sehr
gut zu der ganzen zynischen Haltung,
die darin besteht, die Werte der Gesellschaft abzulehnen und
sich auf das zu konzentrieren, was wirklich zählt, was ist, wenn
es wirklich möglich ist  Tugend und
Selbstgenügsamkeit, also die Idee des Lebens,
zum Beispiel auf der Straße leben oder
ohne Reichtum auskommen, dies sind Ideen
, die die Zyniker unterstützen, indem sie sagen,
je mehr man ohne leben kann, desto
autarker sei man und sollte man
auch  Im Einklang mit der Natur zu leben und
nicht im Einklang mit den Erwartungen
der Gesellschaft, und so versucht
sie jetzt früh zu leben, besonders in der
Geschichte des Stoizismus gibt es viele
Überschneidungen zwischen Stokes, den Stoikern und
den Zynikern, also besonders das, was Sie
von Kin-Yuen wissen  wen ich zuvor erwähnt habe, ist
der Begründer des Stoizismus,
man könnte ihn sich fast wie einen
zynischen Philosophen vorstellen, also schrieb er ein
Werk mit dem Titel „Republik tatsächlich gewählte
Republik“, in dem er vorschlug, wie
die Gesellschaft organisiert sein sollte, und
all das macht  von schockierenden Vorschlägen,
einschließlich Vorschlägen, die uns daran
erinnern, wie Frauen
und Kinder
in der Republik so geteilt werden würden  In Zino gibt es
vielleicht eine Art protofeministische
Strömung und es gibt einen anderen frühen Stoiker,
der ein Werk geschrieben hat, das heißt, dass die Tugend der
Frau dieselbe ist wie die Tugend eines Mannes, der
unglücklich bei der Arbeit ist, aber der
Titel erzählt später seine eigene Geschichte
In der römischen stoischen Tradition haben wir
einen Philosophen namens Sonia's Rufus
, der für denselben Vorschlag argumentiert, also ist
dies eine Art kontinuierlicher Dampf und
stoische Philosophie, und es passt tatsächlich
gut zu einer allgemeinen These der stoischen
Philosophie, die besagt, dass alle Menschen bei sind
am wenigsten
vollkommen rational, also sind wir
durch und durch rational. Wenn wir schlechte Dinge tun,
liegt das nur daran, dass wir die falschen
Überzeugungen haben, es liegt nicht daran, dass wir rationale Wünsche haben
, die wir nicht
kontrollieren können. Es sind immer unsere Handlungen und
unsere Entscheidungen  Ergebnis der Dinge, die
wir über die Welt glauben, so dass wir, wenn wir
nur einen Grund richtig finden könnten und
Wissen darüber hätten, wie die Dinge wirklich
sind, immer alles richtig machen würden
, das ist die Art  eines zentralen Teils der
stoischen Ethikphilosophie und sie denken, dass
dies für alle Menschen gilt, daher ist eine
interessante Frage über die
Stoiker, was sie über Menschen gesagt haben
, die aufgrund ihrer Klasse oder ihres Geschlechts misshandelt werden,
also eine Sache, die
sehr angezogen wird  der Diskussionen im Laufe
der Jahre unter Gelehrten, ich meine,
es ist das, was die Stoiker über die Sklaverei zu sagen haben,
und hier gibt es ein bisschen eine gemischte Tüte.
Wahrscheinlich ist das erste, was
mir hier in den Sinn kommt, einer der
berühmtesten Stoiker und die Geschichte von
Epiktet  lebte dort nur eine Zeit lang war er
selbst ein Sklave, und daher würde man
eher annehmen, dass dies paradigmatisch für
die stoische Einstellung ist, dass sogar ein
Sklave ein Philosoph sein kann, und das
kommt sicherlich teilweise in dem Sinne aus seiner eigenen Philosophie,
aber nicht in dem
er will die Sklaverei abschaffen, als
würde er in gewisser Weise sagen, dass es keine
Rolle spielt, ob du ein Sklave bist, denn
egal wer du bist, du kannst immer noch
tugendhaft sein, indem du die Kontrolle über dich hast  Eigene
Entscheidungen Niemand Ich begann eine
Art Herzstückbeispiel für diese
stoische Herzstückidee, dass, wenn Sie
nur Ihre Überzeugungen richtig machen
und Tugend und Wahrheit verfolgen können, dann werden Sie ein
guter, glücklicher Mensch, und das ist sehr
mühsam  Ich möchte sagen,
ob dies auch für Frauen gilt. Ja, das ist
zumindest ihre offizielle Geschichte.
Daher ist die Tugend einer Frau dieselbe
wie die Tugend eines Mannes. Das
bedeutet also, dass die Frauen
versuchen sollten, die Kontrolle darüber zu erlangen  ihre Vernunft
und die richtigen Überzeugungen haben, so
wie Männer es sollten, so wie sogar Sklaven und
Frauen dazu fähig sind, kann das
einzige sein, was ein Geheimnis ist,
all dies wären Kinder, weil
sie nicht bereit sind, es zu tun
, obwohl sie das gesagt haben  Ich habe erwähnt, dass
Epiktet nicht argumentiert, dass wir
die Sklaverei abschaffen sollten, obwohl wir ein
Sklave waren, und im Allgemeinen argumentieren die Stoiker nicht
dafür, dass manchmal argumentiert wird, dass
Sie Ihre Website genauso behandeln sollten oder
zum Beispiel, dass Sie es sein sollten  verachten
es, mit Ihren Sklaven zu Abend zu essen, aber sie
versuchen nicht, eine Kampagne zur Abschaffung der Sklaverei zu führen,
was wirklich schade ist,
denn es gab einmal einen Stoiker,
der römischer Kaiser war, nämlich Marcus Aurelius,
und wenn er die Sklaverei hätte abschaffen wollen
Er hätte wirklich
etwas dagegen tun können,
würde ich mir vorstellen, aber das ist nie
etwas von den Stoikern, das wirklich dafür argumentiert
, und in gewisser Weise kann man verstehen
, warum sie es nicht tun würden, weil sie denken, dass
die Situation, in der man sich im
Leben befindet, so ist  nicht wirklich ausschlaggebend dafür,
ob du ein guter und glücklicher
Mensch bist, was bestimmt, ob du ein
guter und glücklicher Mensch bist, ist, wie du
darauf reagierst und wie
du deinen eigenen Willen und deine eigenen
Überzeugungen und deine eigenen Entscheidungen kontrollieren würdest  Zitat
Matthias, er sagt, du kannst mein Bein fesseln,
aber du kannst meinen Willen nicht fesseln. Selbst wenn
du ein Gefangener warst, der in einem Gefängnis angekettet war,
wurden sie
von einem Tyrannen mit dem Tod bedroht. Ich meine, alles, alle
möglichen schrecklichen Dinge, die passieren  ppen
zu Ihnen, aber Sie können immer noch darauf reagieren,
indem Sie so tugendhaft sind, wie Sie unter
den Umständen sein können, und so ähnlich ist die
Botschaft, die die Stoiker an Frauen richten würden,
vermutlich so etwas wie „
Akzeptieren Sie Ihre Partnerrolle als Frau, was
wahrscheinlich bedeutet, dass Sie“  Sie sind für die
Führung des Haushalts verantwortlich, aber wenn Sie dies tun,
stellen Sie sicher, dass Sie alles, was
Sie tun, auf eine Weise tun, die mit der Tugend übereinstimmt,
also ist dies fast wie die
Kehrseite von etwas, das Marcus
in seinen Meditationen wirklich über sich selbst einschätzt  Es ist wirklich anstrengend
, der Kaiser zu sein, und alles, was er tun kann,
ist, seine Pflichten als
Kaiser so gut wie möglich zu erfüllen, und
das gilt für alle, also muss ein
Bauer oder ein Geschäftsmann oder wer
auch immer seine Rolle spielen  dass der
Kosmos sie am tugendhaftesten zugewiesen hat,
also gilt dasselbe für Frauen, und
dies könnte erklären, dass der Stoiker, den ich
zuvor erwähnt habe, Sonias Rufus war, der
tatsächlich zu diesem Thema über Frauen brach,
sagt t  as ein Grund, warum wir wollen, dass Frauen
tugendhaft sind, ist, damit sie den
Haushalt tugendhaft führen können, also gibt er
mit einer Hand, nimmt mit der anderen,
vielleicht aus moderner feministischer Sicht,
und die Stuarts tun es im Allgemeinen so
, dass sie sagen, dass Frauen es sein können  tugendhaft wie
Sie, genau wie Männer sein können, aber sie
können nicht unbedingt erwarten, dass dieser Toast
zu ihrer Rettung kommt und sie von der Hausarbeit befreit,
zum Beispiel ist der Stowe
einfach im Allgemeinen der Meinung, dass Sie
jede Rolle spielen sollten, die
Ihnen vom Kosmos zugewiesen wurde  Schicksal und bei Gott okay,
das ist also ziemlich genau das, was wir
mit Frauen in der
hellenistischen Zeit finden. Was ist mit der Spätantike?
Nun, das erste, was zu sagen
ist, ist wahrscheinlich, dass es
in der Spätantike sicherlich weibliche Philosophen gab,
also wissen wir zum Beispiel, dass dort  waren
frauen, die im dritten jahrhundert zum kreis derer gehörten
, die platinis unterricht besuchten,
und im allgemeinen scheint es,
als hätten sie sich
platons empfehlung in der republ zu Herzen genommen  ic, dass
Frauen Philosophen sein können, also ist das gut,
vielleicht eine Kopie davon, dass wir vielleicht
denken, dass dies einfach daran liegt, dass
sie bereits eine Republik haben und sie
dachten, oh, ich verstehe, Frauen können
Philosophen sein, tatsächlich sollten Frauen
Königinnen sein, vielleicht sollten sie es tun  Neben den
Kaiser-Schwerpunkten finden wir sie nicht, die dafür
argumentieren, und tatsächlich, wenn
es nicht so viele Diskussionen über die
Passagen in der Republik über Frauen in
der Spätantike von Playlists gibt, haben wir
einen Kommentar oder wirklich eine Reihe von Essays
über die Republik von einem spätantiken
Platanus namens Propolis und wenn er
zu dem Teil über Frauen kommt, sagt er tatsächlich,
dass man unterscheiden muss zwischen
dem, was Platon in
der Republik
sagt, und dem, was Platon anderswo sagt, besonders
in unserem späteren Dialog genannt  Verlust und in
den Gesetzen haben Sie eine viel weniger großzügige
Diskussion über Frauen, die nicht
betont, dass sie Herrscher sein können und
dass sie Philosophen sein können, und so
versuchen, diesen Disp zu lösen  Die Arität
zwischen den beiden Texten verspricht mit Sicherheit,
dass Frauen in einer idealen perfekten Gesellschaft
mit Männern regieren und
Philosophen sein würden, aber im wirklichen Leben ist
es eher wie in den Gesetzen, wo
sie die Art von Taten ausführen, die wir
von ihnen erwarten  Ich würde also denken,
dass dies auf Ihre Frage die Idee aufwirft,
dass die Anwesenheit von Philosophinnen
in der plattenlosen Tradition in der
Spätantike direkt auf den
Rat zurückzuführen ist, der in der Republik gegeben wurde, der
sicherlich etwas damit zu tun
hatte, aber ich denke  Es ist bezeichnend, dass er in
dem einen Fall, in dem wir eine alte
Klinge haben, die am direktesten mit der Republik zu tun hat, im
Grunde sagt, ja
, das ist alles theoretisch richtig, aber im wirklichen
Leben ist es wahrscheinlich nicht sehr relevant. Ich habe
tatsächlich eine Art Verdacht oder
Theorie darüber warum  Schlichtheit war vielleicht
besonders anfällig dafür, Frauen zu ermutigen,
Philosophen zu werden, und ich kann dies nicht
wirklich mit historischen Beweisen belegen, aber
ich werde es trotzdem sagen, weil ich dünn bin  k
Es könnte wahr sein, also ist jemand
relevant für etwas anderes, was
relevant sein könnte, was in diesem Denken
über die Seele gespielt wurde, und dies würde auch
für die Fagor Ians gelten, also was
denken sie über die Seele, was sie
denken, dass die  Die Seele ist eine immaterielle
Substanz, die den Tod des Körpers überleben kann.
Platon argumentiert
ausdrücklich dafür in einem Dialog namens Pheo
, dem Dialog, an dessen Ende
Sokrates Gift nimmt und stirbt
und dann überleben
und in einen anderen Körper zurückkehren, und dieser andere
Körper könnte
der Körper eines nichtmenschlichen Tieres sein, und es
könnte auch der Körper einer Frau sein, ähnlich
könnte die Seele einer Frau ihren Körper verlassen,
in den Körper eines Mannes gehen, und ich denke, das,
wenn Sie  Sind Sie die Art von Verlust von ihr, die
Menschen in erster Linie als körperlose
Seelen betrachtet, die sich im Moment in einem Körper befinden,
dann denken Sie wahrscheinlich viel weniger
, dass die Menschen
irgendwie rigoros geteilt werden sollten  in Männer und
Frauen, weil wirklich alles, was wir haben, seine
Seelen hat, die, soweit ich sehen kann, überhaupt kein
Geschlecht haben, die dann männliche und
weibliche Körper annehmen, während, wenn Sie eher
aristotelisch sind, Sie denken, dass die
Seele die Form der ist  Körper, es hat eine sehr
enge Verbindung mit dem Körper, dann werden
Sie vielleicht gebeten zu denken, dass
es einen großen Unterschied für Ihre Seele macht,
ob Sie männlich oder weiblich sind.
Ich glaube, ich habe erwähnt, als
ich über Aristoteles sprach, dass es
psychologisch ist  Die Theorie würde ihn irgendwie dazu drängen
, zu denken, dass
Männer sich von Natur aus
in Bezug auf ihre rationalen Fähigkeiten stark von Frauen unterscheiden
, so dass es
auch in der Spätantike so sein wird, dass die
Erwartungen an Frauen im Allgemeinen
in gewissem Sinne niedriger sind  als die Erwartungen
von Männern, daher wird es
von den meisten Intellektuellen in der Antike immer noch als selbstverständlich angesehen,
dass Frauen eher dazu
neigen, leidenschaftlich zu sein oder eher
emotional und so weiter und pervers  oder
ironischerweise bedeutet das, dass
Frauen besondere Anerkennung erhalten, wenn sie
ihre Leidenschaften und Triebe und ihre Wünsche überwinden können. Es
gibt etwas, das
wir später im Mittelalter wiedersehen werden,
also ist die Idee hier, dass
Frauen irgendwie in Versuchung geführt werden  Sexuelles
Verlangen wäre eigentlich ein Fall, aber
Verlangen im Allgemeinen neigen dazu,
die Kontrolle über ihre Rationalität zu verlieren, wenn
sie rational bleiben und
sich selbst unter Kontrolle halten. Sie sind
besonders bewundernswert, und etwas
, das hier sehr auffällig geworden ist, ist
das The Philosopher's Who  wir sehen, und sie werden
sowohl auf der heidnischen als auch auf der christlichen
Seite oft besonders gelobt,
weil sie so immun gegen die Art
des Rufs des Körpers oder der Beherrschung des
Verlangens waren, und dies geht tatsächlich mit
etwas einher, das tatsächlich erwähnt werden kann
Anfangs ist das in der
Spätantike in der Römerzeit allgemein, wenn
jemand als Philosoph bezeichnet wird
, muss das nicht unbedingt heißen, dass er es ist
ein Philosoph in unserem Sinne waren, mit anderen
Worten, es bedeutet nicht unbedingt, dass
sie Abhandlungen über Ethik,
Metaphysik und Erkenntnistheorie geschrieben haben, er könnte
eigentlich nur meinen, dass sie versucht haben
, ein tugendhaftes Leben zu führen, also
haben Sie manchmal zum Beispiel Grabsteine, auf denen steht, dass
hier jemand liegt  er oder sie war also ein
Philosoph und das könnte nur bedeuten, dass er
oder sie ein wirklich guter Mensch war, da er
oder sie sich wirklich der
Tugend widmen konnte, und manchmal, wenn Sie
Philosophen sehen, die Frauen sind, und sie sich
sowohl unter Christen als auch unter
Heiden identifizieren, wenn sie es tun  Philosophen werden
sie manchmal so genannt, gerade
weil sie sich im Leben des Geistes so der Tugend verschrieben haben,
aber nicht immer, und hier ist natürlich Hypatia der paradigmatische
Fall und bei weitem der berühmteste Fall
eines Philosophen aus der Antike
Von einem Römer
durch ein christliches Gesetz in Alexandria getötet, wo
sie jetzt ein Problem war. Hypatia
war in erster Linie Mathematikerin, keine
Philosophin, und tatsächlich gibt es eine  Ich
frage mich hier, inwieweit
wir sie überhaupt als eine Hauptfigur
in der Geschichte der Philosophie betrachten können, im Gegensatz
zu einer Hauptfigur in der Geschichte
der Mathematik, die ein intellektuelles
Unterfangen im Allgemeinen ist, jetzt ist sie in gewisser Weise eine
ziemlich einzigartige Figur  Zum einen
wurde ihr von Christian Mob erzählt,
dass dies
ein sehr wichtiges Ereignis in der Geschichte von
Alexandria war. Sie wissen vielleicht, dass
tatsächlich ein Film über das
Leben von Hypatia
namens Agora gedreht wurde, damit Sie sich das ansehen
können  irgendwie interessant, weil es
die Christen der damaligen Zeit irgendwie
als religiöse Fanatiker mit langen Bärten
und schwarzen Gewändern und allem so darstellt,
als ob Christen der Spätantike
wie die Taliban wären und auf der anderen
Seite haben Sie die Heiden so in diesem Film oder
Im Grunde sind die Guten und die
wichtigsten Guten Hypatia,
und in der Tat ist das für manche bis zu einem gewissen
Grad nicht falsch, zumindest insofern, als
Hypatia zum Opfer fiel  Spannungen
zwischen Heiden und Christen, so
dass es
damals zu einem politischen Streit zwischen dem
Gouverneur von Alexandria,
dem gleichnamigen römischen Gouverneur, und
dem christlichen Bischof von
Alexandria namens Kyrill kam, mit dem Hypatia
besonders eng verbunden war
Orestes und die Christen dachten, dass
sie einen schädlichen Einfluss
auf einen Mob ausübte, der sie vielleicht einschüchtern
wollte. Es ist nicht wirklich klar, was
sie im Sinn hatten, aber als sie sie fanden,
hatte sie nicht damit gerechnet, also war
sie nicht gut verteidigt  und sie rissen ihr die
Kleider vom Leib, schlugen sie zusammen und töteten sie,
so offensichtlich ein schreckliches Ereignis, und es
schockierte tatsächlich sowohl Christen als auch
Heiden in der Stadt und wurde
von späteren Autoren besprochen
Eine weitere Besonderheit an ihr
ist, dass sie tatsächlich eine philosophische
Schule leitete, die sie von ihrem
Vater Theon von Alexandria geerbt hatte, der wie
sie eine Mutter war  Themamatikerin, also stellt sich
für uns hier die Frage, inwieweit war sie
Philosophin, inwieweit ist sie
Mathematikerin, sie ist sicherlich eine Denkerin
oder eine Denkerin und in der späten
Antike fällt sie offensichtlich unter unsere Rubrik
in dieser Vortragsreihe und hier nicht
ganz  Klar, so ist eine der wichtigsten
Quellen für
Geduld der zweischichtige Neuplatoniker namens
Damaskus, der eine Biographie eines
anderen Philosophen namens Isadora schrieb und
darin eine Art Bild von einer
ganzen Reihe von Intellektuellen aus dem
spätantiken Satanismus und einem von ihnen im
Zitat und  Irgendwann kommt er dazu
, Hypatia mit Isadora als Hauptfigur zu vergleichen,
und er sagt, diese Isadora
Hypatia sei sehr anders, nicht nur weil sich
ein Mann von einer Frau unterscheidet, sondern als wahrer
Philosoph unterscheidet sie sich von einem
Mathematiker, also sollten wir meiner Meinung nach
zuerst sagen  was es bedeuten würde, wenn sie
wirklich nur eine Mathematikerin
wäre, also wäre das zunächst einmal schon
ziemlich interessant und aufregend, also war
sie eindeutig eine sehr a  Als fortgeschrittene
Mathematikerin schrieb sie Arbeiten über Ptolemäus,
und in dieser Hinsicht kann sie
mit mehreren anderen, wenn nicht Fluffern als
Mathematikern in der Antike verglichen werden,
so wissen wir zum Beispiel von einer
anderen Mathematikerin in Panthro
Zeon, die
von einem männlichen Philosophen namens Papas who ziemlich spöttisch kritisiert wurde
sagte im Grunde herablassend, dass sie
grundlegende Mathematik nicht verstehe, also
würde Hypatia in diesem Sinne irgendwie in ein
Muster von späten weiblichen
Intellektuellen passen, die sich für Mathematik interessierten,
und wir könnten uns fragen, warum
dies eine offensichtliche Teilantwort sein könnte
, mit der sie verbunden ist  diese langjährige
Tradition, Frauen mit dem
Pythagoräismus zu verbinden, denn natürlich waren die
Pythagoräer mit der Mathematik verwandt,
aber es gibt auch einige Hinweise
darauf, dass Hypatia auch philosophisches
Interesse hatte und in dieser
Hinsicht nicht einzigartig wäre, also könnten wir hier darauf
schauen  eine andere Gruppe von Philosophen in meinem
Haus
in Athen, zu denen der von mir
erwähnte Denker gehörte  Ich habe nämlich demjenigen versprochen,
der Platons Republik kommentierte, also hieß
es tatsächlich in einer Biographie eines Studentenmarinus über ihn,
dass er
wichtige Dinge über heidnische Philosophie
und Rituale von einer Frau gelernt habe, also lassen Sie mich
Ihnen diesen Text aus dem Leben von geben
Propolis von Mariahs Propheten erhielt
diese Dinge und lernte ihre
Bedeutung und Anwendung von
Östrogen Ayane, der Tochter von Plutarch,
denn die Riten und der gesamte
Theaterunterricht werden von ihr allein bewahrt,
weil sie von ihrem Vater zu ihr hinuntergeleitet wurden
und wir tatsächlich einige
Beweise dafür haben, dass Hypatia  Philosophie zu sprechen,
so wie es eine Unterbrechung ni offenbar
in Athen tat, und dass sie
von
einer Reihe ihrer Schüler, von denen einige
übrigens Christen waren, als große Weise und Art von Ehrenlehrerin angesehen wurde, insbesondere
gab es einen christlichen Schüler oder seinen
Namen  Die gleiche Leichtigkeit, die tatsächlich
Bischof wurde, der kein Christ war, und
er wurde von ihr ausgebildet und schrieb
ihr mehrere Briefe, von denen wir  Diese
verraten leider nicht viel über Hypatias Ideen,
aber sie
zeigen uns unter anderem, dass Hypatia von
Synesius vor ihrem Tod als sehr
mächtig und einflussreich angesehen wurde, weil ein Teil dessen,
was er in diesen Briefen tut,
versucht, sie dazu zu bringen  nutze ihr politisches
Gütesiegel und ihren Einfluss, um seinen Freunden zu helfen,
also war sie wirklich eine ziemlich prominente
Person in Nova Sangria, wie du vielleicht
ohnehin aus der Tatsache erraten kannst, dass dieser
christliche Mobb Deep es wert ist, getötet zu werden,
weil sie eine Verbündete dieses verhassten
römischen Gouverneurs war  Insgesamt neige ich eigentlich
zu der Meinung, dass
Hypatia eindeutig eine sehr faszinierende Figur
ist, die vielleicht über das hinausgeht, was sie sein
sollte, wenn wir sie als die
wichtigste Laienphilosophin der Antike betrachten.
Ich denke, der Grund dafür ist
offensichtlich der spektakuläre und tragische Tod  in diesem wirklich interessanten
Kontrast zwischen Heidentum und
Christentum, der für
die Zeit so wichtig ist, so absolut super
faszinierend und ich  Ich denke, es ist
wahrscheinlich richtig zu sagen, dass sie eine
Platanus-Philosophin war und sie dabei erwischt wurde
, wie sie diese Philosophie in ihrer Schule bekämpft hat,
aber ich denke nicht, dass es viele Beweise gibt
, die wir verwenden können, um ihre Lehre zu rekonstruieren
, und daher denke ich, dass
es interessantere Darstellungen gibt  von
anderen Denkerinnen ungefähr zur gleichen
Zeit, also sind wir wieder hier in der Zeit, in der
das Heidentum wie eine Koexistenz mit dem
Christentum ist, und ich werde jetzt über
zwei von ihnen sprechen, sie sind beides, und das ist
meiner Meinung nach ein aufschlussreiches Detail.
Sie sind uns beide bekannt, weil
sie mit berühmten Männern verwandt waren. Die
erste, über die ich sprechen werde, ist Monica,
die die Mutter von Saint Agustin war. Die
zweite Person, über die ich sprechen werde, ist
seine Macrina, die die Schwester von
Gregory war  von Nyssa und dies sind beide sehr
wichtige Persönlichkeiten in der Geschichte der
Kirche. Gustin ist ein lateinischer Kirchenvater,
natürlich in Latein,
er wurde in Nordafrika geboren, lebte auch
in Italien, ging zurück nach Nordafrika,
Gregor von New York  ssa waren auf Griechisch und es ist
eine wichtige Figur auf dieser Route, die
byzantinische oder östliche Kirche, die orthodoxe
Kirche, und er lebte in Kappadokien,
das in der heutigen Türkei liegt, also haben wir, wie ich bereits sagte
,
keine Werke von Pokemon McCormick  die
Gustin und Gregory, wo sie uns
über Monica und Macrina erzählen und sie
sagen interessante Dinge über sie Dinge
, die meiner Meinung nach ziemlich glaubwürdige
Beweise dafür sind, dass diese Leute ernsthafte
Denker waren und auch viel Einfluss
auf Agustin bzw. Gregory hatten,
also fangen wir an  Mit Monica ist Monica
eine sehr starke Präsenz in den Werken
des Kunden, und sie erscheint zum einen in
mehreren seiner Schriften, insbesondere
in
frühen Schriften, von denen einige die
Form philosophischer Dialoge annehmen, hier
könnten wir Platon tatsächlich als einen
größeren Vergleich betrachten  und manchmal kommt in diesen
Dialogen, in denen Cussin normalerweise
mit jungen Freunden von ihm spricht oder
mit ihm zusammen Christ wird,
Monica herein  ein weiterer Gesprächspartner und
sie ist oft im Ausland und hat eine Art
Erhöhung der Einsätze oder ist eine
besonders weise Person, deren Ansichten
sehr ernst genommen werden, also ist es nicht ganz so,
als ob Sokrates auftaucht, sondern als
ob sich vielleicht eine ältere oder weisere Person
gewendet hat  up trägt zum
Gespräch bei und wird in keiner
Weise als Frau herabgesetzt, die
überhaupt nicht auf den Karten zu sein scheint, aber diese
vier Spuren von ihr, aber die lebendigste
Darstellung von Monica sind in Agustíns Werk
die Geständnisse, die in  allgemein ist
einer der bemerkenswertesten Texte aus der
Antike oder aus der Antike.  Es ist in
gewisser Weise die allererste spirituelle oder
psychologische Autobiographie. Es ist Agustin
, der die Geschichte erzählt, wie er
von einem Nichtchristen zu einem
Christen wurde, und dann über die
anhaltenden Zweifel spricht, die er selbst nach seiner
Konvertierung zum Christentum hatte, also gibt es eine
Menge  man kann über die beichten
und über die rolle von monika darin sagen, um es kurz zu
machen: monika
spielt eine wichtige rolle, weil sie schon
sehr früh in agustíns
leben diejenige ist, die ihn immer dazu drängt
, zum christentum zu konvertieren, weil sie eine
sehr fromme christin ist  sehr überzeugter
Christ und sie versucht, ihn dazu
zu bringen, von seinen bösen Wegen abzuweichen und
selbst ein guter Christ zu werden, also ist sie fast
wie seine spirituelle Führerin in der
spirituellen Führerin, und ein Großteil der
dramatischen Spannung im Seil in den
Bekenntnissen kommt von der  Frage,
wie lange es dauern wird
, ihr endlich irgendwie zuzuhören, und
natürlich sollten die Leser
mit ihr sympathisieren und mit ihm mitfiebern
Zum Christentum zu konvertieren, der Ton
von all dem ist gut eingefangen und vielleicht
die berühmteste Zeile aus den
Bekenntnissen, in denen Agustin
über seine Bemühungen spricht,
tugendhaft zu werden und ein guter Mensch zu werden, der ein
guter Christ sein kann, und er sagt, dass dies für eine
Weile sein ist  Seine Einstellung wurde in einem
Gebet zusammengefasst, das er Gott gab, wo er sagte:
O Herr, mach mich tugendhaft, aber noch nicht, also
genießt er immer noch seine Sünde und möchte es
irgendwie tun, obwohl es noch eine Weile
dauert, bis er endlich auf die
richtige Spur kommt  eng, also ist Monica
aus diesem Grund während der gesamten Geständnisse wichtig,
aber dann gibt es diese
Höhepunktszene in den Geständnissen, die in gewisser
Weise die wichtigste Szene ist,
in der er mit ihr in der Stadt Ostia ist.
Gegen Ende ihres Lebens wird sie
einfach sterben  Ein paar Seiten später in
der Geschichte führen sie und Dustin diese
intensiven Gespräche über vielleicht
Philosophie und Religion und dann
haben sie eine Art mystische Vision, in die
Agustin hineingebracht wird  Es war
Gott von Angesicht zu Angesicht, also ist diese Passage wirklich
lesenswert, und hier
führte uns das Gespräch zu dem
Schluss, dass die Freuden der
körperlichen Sinne, so herrlich sie im
strahlenden Licht dieser physischen Welt auch sein
mögen, im Vergleich mit einem Licht mit gesehen werden  ein
Leben der Ewigkeit, das nicht einmal der Erwägung wert ist,
dass unser Geist von
einer glühenden Zuneigung zum ewigen
Sein selbst erhoben wurde. Schritt für Schritt stiegen wir
über alle körperlichen Objekte und den
Himmel selbst hinaus. Wir ersteigen ihn noch weiter
durch innere Reflexion und Dialog und
Staunen über Ihr  Worte und wir traten in
unseren eigenen Geist ein, wir bewegen uns über sie hinaus
, um die Region der unerschöpflichen Fülle zu erreichen,
ihr Leben ist die Weisheit, durch
die alle Geschöpfe entstehen, sowohl
Dinge, die waren als auch Dinge, die sein werden, aber die
Weisheit selbst hat nicht ins Leben gerufen
aber ist es und wird es
immer in dieser Weisheit sein, dass
es keine vergängliche Zukunft gibt, sondern nur das Sein,
da es ewig ist, also können wir hier sehen, dass
Gustin tatsächlich refe  Das führt zu
vielen Ideen, die sehr platonistisch sind, und
das macht Sinn, denn etwas anderes
, was er in den Bekenntnissen sagt, ist, dass
er
größtenteils durch das Studium des Platonismus zum Christentum gebracht wurde, so dass wir in gewisser
Weise sehen können, wie Monica
gebracht wurde  hier als spiritueller Führer
zusammen mit Themen aus der platonischen
Tradition zu dieser Idee der göttlichen Ursache,
die jenseits aller körperlichen Dinge und
sogar jenseits der Zeit ist, also gibt es keine
Vergangenheit, Gegenwart oder Zukunft über Gott, es gibt
nur diese Art von Ewigkeit, jetzt ist er einfach
so unveränderlich perfekt  Göttlichkeit und in
dieser Vision, die Agustin Monica gemeinsam teilte, wird
ihnen die Chance gewährt,
diese Göttlichkeit zu sehen, und dies ist sozusagen
der ultimative Moment, der einen Gustin
aus seinen bösen Wegen schockt und er versucht,
die Sünde hinter sich zu lassen und ein guter
Christ und so zu werden  Ich sagte nur ein paar Seiten
später, dass wir tatsächlich Monicas
Todesszene haben und es wird wirklich unterstrichen, wie
sehr ihre Rolle in der Geschichte darin besteht, sein
Führer zum Christentum zu sein  Das ist
die Passage mit ihren letzten Worten
sagt sie Sam mein Sohn ich finde jetzt keine Freude mehr
an diesem Leben was ich hier noch zu tun
habe und warum ich hier bin weiß ich nicht meine
Hoffnung in dieser Welt hat sich schon erfüllt
die eine  Grund, warum ich
länger in diesem Leben bleiben wollte, war mein Wunsch,
dich vor meinem Tod als katholischen Christen zu sehen,
mein Gott hat dies in einer Weise mehr gewährt,
als ich
gehofft hatte  Worte von Monica dort
und man sieht, dass Justin sie
ernst nimmt, sowohl als eine Art ethisches
Paradigma, aber auch als das so nette Ding, ich
würde sagen, unsere philosophische Figur, also wird
sie sowohl
tatsächlich als auch spirituell ernst genommen, und wie
gesagt, es gibt wirklich nie welche
Soweit ich das beurteilen kann, wurde Augusta
Monica aufgrund ihres Geschlechts von der Stufe
einer religiösen Weisen
herabgestuft. Ich denke, wenn Sie
sagen wollten, dass irgendetwas
an der Darstellung von M. unter sexistisch oder unbefriedigend ist
onica es könnte sein, dass ihre
rolle in der geschichte wirklich immer
nebensächlich zu der geschichte über agustíns eigene spirituelle karriere ist, also sehen wir
nie, wie sie sich entwickelt, wir sehen sie nie
mit zweifeln konfrontiert all die tiefgründige
psychologie der beichten, wie immer
in agustíns psychologie ist meine tante
Monica, also ist sie eine Art
Nebenfigur, aber sie ist eine sehr wichtige
Nebenfigur und man wird
mit viel Respekt behandelt. Ich denke, wir sollten alle
hoffen, von unseren
Kindern in ihrer Autobiografie
so gut behandelt zu werden
Von ihren Familienmitgliedern viel Respekt
Wenden wir uns nun Mike Rena zu, der, wie
gesagt, die Schwester von Gregor von Nyssa ist,
einem der wichtigsten griechischen Väter
und Quellen der byzantinischen Theologie und
Philosophie,
also hat er möglicherweise noch nichts von ihm
gehört  genau ein bekannter Name, aber er ist
einer der wenigen frühgriechischen christlichen
Schriftsteller, die dann wirklich sehr
einflussreich für die gesamte spätere orthodoxe
Tradition sind, eigentlich sind es drei
Cappadocia
Fathers basil and and - Gregorys
Gregory-Designs hat er und Gregory von
Nyssa, also reden wir davon, dass Gregory sich
selbst hilft, also verwechseln Sie ihn nicht
mit dem anderen Gregory, und dieser Gregory
hat zwei Werke geschrieben, die sich mit seiner Schwester Macrina befassen,
die ich eigentlich sagen würde  wir
sollten fast wie eine Kappadokierin der vierten Klasse behandeln,
also ist sie jemand, über den wir wiederum nicht
unbedingt viel direkt wissen, weil
wir nur durch die
Werke von Gregory etwas über sie erfahren, aber er schreibt über sie
auf eine Weise, die darauf hindeutet, wenn überhaupt
Sie ist der überlegene Intellekt und die
überlegene
kleine Figur der überlegenen Sphäre, also sieht er zu ihr als
Lehrerin auf und bis er sie mit
viel Respekt behandelt, also gibt es hier zwei Werke, von denen
ich nur kurz erwähnen möchte, dass es ein
Werk namens Das Leben von Macrina gibt  ist im
Grunde eine Hagiographie
von ihr, also das Leben der Heiligen,
geschrieben von Gregory, und du denkst vielleicht, meine
Güte, warum rede ich nur darüber
, dass das wirklich aufregend klingt, es
muss Loa geben  ds ihrer Ideen darin und
der Grund, warum ich es nicht bin, ist, dass er sie, obwohl es
ein interessanter Text ist, nicht
wirklich als Philosophin
darstellt, sondern sich hauptsächlich auf ihre
Errungenschaften als eine Art spirituelle
Heldin und ihre Fähigkeit konzentriert  Wunder zu wirken
und solche Dinge, also ist es eher eine
Geschichte über spätantike christliche
asketische spirituelle Tugend, und wenn alles, was wir
hätten, wäre, dass Sie wirklich nur
in ein breiteres Muster der Behandlung von
Frauen in der spätchristlichen Literatur passen würden,
also ganz allgemein in der Antike  In der christlichen
Literatur gibt es viele Werke
, die diese geistlichen Helden preisen,
zum Beispiel Antonius der Große, von
denen einige in die Wüste gingen oder
an der Spitze einer Säule lebten, wie Samia und
das Oberlicht, oder in einer Höhle lebten
oder ohne zu essen gingen  wochenlang die reihe von
etcetera etcetera, das ist also die
bewegung, die manchmal als christliche
asketik bezeichnet wird, und einige der asketen
fragen nach frauen, und wir schreiben
über diese arbeit
Macrina passt irgendwie in dieses Modell, also ist es eine
Biografie von ihr als eine tugendhafte Heilige
, die meiner Meinung nach Dinge tut, wie sich auf wundersame Weise
von Krankheiten zu erholen,
obwohl die interessantere Arbeit
mit Macrina eine Arbeit ist, die
die Seele und den Intellekt fordert, und das ist
wirklich faszinierend  ist ein Dialog
zwischen Gregor zu sich selbst und McCrea, also ist
der Aufbau so, dass Gregor, sein Bruder,
gerade gestorben ist und er sich von
seiner Schwester Macrina trösten lässt, aber er findet, dass
sie auch im Sterben liegt, sie liegt auf ihrem Sterbebett, und
so ist er sehr verzweifelt und sie dann
Führen Sie ein Gespräch darüber, ob
die Seele unsterblich ist oder nicht, also kommen Sie vielleicht schon
, um dies zu besuchen, aber das klingt sehr
nach einem anderen Dialog, als ich
tatsächlich vor ein paar Minuten
Platons Phaedo erwähnte, also haben wir hier
eine Dialogfunktion von jemandem, der es ist
kurz vor dem Tod
, der darüber streitet, ob die
Seele unsterblich ist oder nicht, und am Ende
stirbt dieser Mensch, da denke ich natürlich
an Platons Phaidon und die
Die Darstellung von Sokrates ist in den letzten Momenten
so offensichtlich, dass es kein
Zufall ist, was Gregory hier tut.
Er erzählt den Phaedo sozusagen nach
, so dass Platons Dialog über die
Unsterblichkeit der Seele, in dem Sie
Sartre beschatten, stirbt und
er seinen letzten verbringt  Momente, in denen über die Unsterblichkeit der Seele diskutiert wurde,
diese Umschreibung aus einer christlichen
Perspektive, aber faszinierend
genug, seine Schwester in die Rolle von
Sokrates zu versetzen,
also gibt es mehrere Punkte, die wir daraus
entnehmen können, vielleicht sollte ich gleich
zu Beginn sagen, dass wir das noch
einmal bedenken sollten  Wir haben
hier Gregorys Worte gelesen und nicht die Worte meiner Karina, und
wir haben wirklich keine Möglichkeit zu wissen,
inwieweit Gregory ihr Worte in den Mund legt.
Wahrscheinlich können wir das
überhaupt nur sagen, wenn wir uns ansehen, was
Gregory über die Seele in anderen sagt
funktioniert und sehen, ob es fast
genau dasselbe ist, aber selbst dann könnten wir
wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass Macrina und
Gregory ziemlich viel darüber einig wären
Natur der Seele und vielleicht können wir
sogar annehmen, dass Melina
Gregorys Denken über die Seele beeinflusst hat,
also denke ich, dass wir in gewisser Weise
wahrscheinlich agnostisch sein sollten, wie viel
Inhalt hier Gregory ist und wie
viel Inhalt
Macrina, also nochmal das  ist in gewisser Weise eine
Art Gottheit, kein Problem, also eine Frau
, die
von einem Mann als Sprecherin benutzt wird, und Sie wissen nicht, ob es
die Ideen des Mannes oder die der Frau sind, aber
eines können wir definitiv über meine
Gemeinschaft sagen und  Dieser Dialog besteht darin, dass
sie auf eine sehr
rationalistische Weise präsentiert wird, also auf eine Art und Weise,
die die Erwartungen der Menschen an
Frauen untergräbt, so dass der Beginn oder die
Passage vom Beginn des
Dialogs ausgeht, also ist dies kurz nachdem sie
hereingekommen ist und gesehen hat, wie krank sie ist  ist und er
sagt, die Stelle, an der die Lehrerin
all meinen Schmerz erweckte, denn sie lag in einem Zustand
der Erschöpfung, sogar bis zum Tod,
gab sie mir für eine Weile wie einen
geschickten Fahrer im unbequemen
vio  Angesichts meiner Trauer und dann versuchte
sie, mich zu kontrollieren, indem sie
mit der Kurve ihrer Argumentation die
Unordnung meiner Seele richtig ansprach, also ist uns
hier aufgefallen, dass die Darstellung von
ihr eigentlich eine Bande sehr nach Sokrates klingt,
also eine Sache  Im
Phaedo passiert, dass Sokrates, seine Familie,
seine Frau und später seine Freunde
als irgendwie emotional
hysterisch dargestellt werden und er die Frau loswird
und sagt: Geh, du weißt schon, lass mich
in Ruhe mit meinen Freunden reden und wann
dann wann  Seine Freunde brechen weinend zusammen,
weil er kurz vor der Hinrichtung steht. Er
sagt, hör auf, dich wie Frauen zu benehmen. Hier haben wir
eine Frau, die Gregory sagt, er solle sich
zusammenreißen und mehr unter Kontrolle haben
Mann, und in der Tat
sagen alte Christen oft
über diese ästhetischen, heldenhaften Frauen, dass
sie so erstaunlich waren, dass es fast so war, als wären
sie nicht verrückt, das ist etwas, was
wir wahrscheinlich tun  heute erschreckend gefunden,
aber in der Antike und im Mittelalter
oft als eine Art Kompliment gezählt
, das man Frauen machte, aber es ist
nicht nur so, dass sie nicht nur
so rational und so ruhig ist und ihre
Sterbemomente es auch so sind  Die Einstellung
passt perfekt zu
Sol, dass sie dann erklärt,
worauf sie in dem Gespräch abzielt, und
es ist wirklich so, wie sie die
ganze schwere Arbeit erledigt, damit sie alle
Ideen hat. Gregory stellt nur
gelegentlich Fragen und erhebt Einwände gegen
Nachfassen  Fragen, aber sie ist die
ganze Zeit die Lehrerin, sie hat eine Theorie von
Sol, die er mit Gregory teilt, und
sie hatte keinen Zweifel daran,
also zögert sie überhaupt nicht, was diese
Theorie angeht und worauf sie seine
Theorien von Sol abzielt, nach denen die
Seele zerstreut wird  Tod, und
was ihr besonders nicht gefällt,
ist die Theorie der hellenistischen Schule, die
ich schon zu Beginn
dieses Vortrags erwähnt habe, nämlich die Epikureer, sie
waren unnachgiebig und  Sie dachten, wenn
ich zum Beispiel sterbe, wird sich meine Seele, die nur
aus einem Haufen Atome besteht, auflösen
und ich bin nicht mehr existent,
und sie sagt, dass dies
unmöglich wahr sein kann, dass es ein separates
immaterielles
psychologisches Prinzip geben muss und der Körper existiert
Offensichtlich ist die Seele, die es
zusammenhält und den Tod
des Körpers und des gesamten Dialogs überleben wird, ihr
Argument dafür, dass eine der zentralen
Möglichkeiten, die sie zu beweisen versucht, darin besteht
, eine Parallele zwischen dem Menschlichen
einerseits und dem Ganzen zu ziehen  Kosmos auf
der anderen Seite, weil sie sagen möchte,
genauso wie der Kosmos ein physisches Objekt ist
, das einen spirituellen Herrscher hat, und mein Gott
, unser Körper ist ein physisches Objekt,
das einen spirituellen Herrscher hat, nämlich das Salz,
also lass mich dir eine Passage darüber vorlesen
Es wurde von Weisen gesagt, dass der
Mensch ein Mikrokosmos ist und
alle Elemente enthält, die das Universum vervollständigen.
Unsere Vorstellung von der Seele ist,
dass sie mit einer besonderen, eigenständigen Natur existiert
Neben dem Körper wird sie
im Wesentlichen durch lebende
Intellektuelle geschaffen, die von sich selbst auf
einen organisierten Empfindungskörper die Kraft des
Lebens und des Greifens von
Empfindungsobjekten übertragen, also würde ich sagen, was sie
hier im Grunde tut, ist die Annahme
einer berühmten Theorie der Seele im Großen und Ganzen
und
hier gibt es so viele Epikureer, die hier einen anderen Heiden eingeben,
andererseits passt das, was sie
sagt, offensichtlich sehr gut zur christlichen
Theologie, also sagt sie, dass die Seele
sich auf den Körper bezieht, wie Gott
sich auf die Welt bezieht, und dies ist eine davon
Ihre zentralen Argumente dafür, warum die Seele
den Tod des Körpers überleben kann, so
wie Gott für seine Existenz nicht
von der Existenz der Welt
abhängt, so hängt die Existenz der Seele nicht von
der Existenz des Körpers ab, also
zieht sie a  viele heidnische Ideen auf der
anderen Seite stellt sie sicher,
dass sie sich nur auf heidnische Ideen verlässt,
soweit sie helfen können, obwohl
ihre Herangehensweise sozusagen nicht so biblisch ist, wie sie es
tut  Ich zitiere Gregor nicht ständig aus der
Bibel, als ob das genug wäre,
und sie kommt nicht als christliche
Theologin rüber, sie kommt eher als
christliche Philosophin, würde ich sagen,
trotzdem distanziert sie sich von
heidnischen Philosophen wie Platon und
kritisiert manchmal heidnische Philosophie
Ansichten, einschließlich etwas, das ich
zuvor erwähnt habe, die Theorie der Reinkarnation,
also beschwert sie sich, dass die Heiden glauben,
dass Seelen von einem Körper zum anderen gehen können,
und sie denkt, dass dies nicht
passiert,
aber sie verbringt viel Zeit
am Ende des Dialogs damit, zu streiten  für die
Möglichkeit der körperlichen Auferstehung,
was natürlich ein eher christliches Thema ist, also ist
die Idee hier keine Reinkarnation, also kein
Geburtszyklus wie
im Buddhismus, sondern ja für die Idee, dass ein
Körper am Ende der
Zeit auferweckt wird  unsere Seele wieder zusammenzubringen, also ist sie in dieser
Hinsicht vielen anderen
christlichen Denkern sehr ähnlich, die
in dem Sinne hin und her gerissen sind, dass ich einerseits
denke, dass wir wahr sind  Das Selbst ist die Seele,
andererseits denken sie, dass die mit der Seele
verbundene Zugehörigkeit mit einem Körper verbunden war und dass
wir am Ende der Zeit einen Körper zurückbekommen sollten,
also ist diese Arbeit mit dem Titel „Leib und
Auferstehung“ oder „Entschuldigung für die Seele und
Auferstehung“ sehr interessant
Philosophisches Werk, es ist eine sehr interessante
Darstellung einer
Denkerin in der Antike, und
tatsächlich ist es meiner Meinung nach, zumindest nach dem,
was ich gelesen habe, das interessanteste
Werk, an dem eine Frau aus der Spätzeit beteiligt ist, und
integriert den
philosophisch reichhaltigsten Text, in dem wir
eine Denkerin als Wesen haben  zu
ihren eigenen Bedingungen präsentiert und
ihre eigenen Argumente für eine Angelegenheit vorbringen zu dürfen, die für sie
von großer Bedeutung ist,
da sie bald sterben wird. Wie sie es
empfehlen, es zu lesen, wird
unsere Geschichte über Denkerinnen in
der Spätantike das nächste Mal abschließen  Wir
werden uns etwas ansehen,
was ich gerade erwähnt habe, nämlich die
indische Tradition, wo wir wiederum
Reinkarnation in der buddhistischen Tradition finden
aber auch vedische oder hinduistische Traditionen und
wir werden uns ziemlich
frühe Texte aus den Oh-Bestrafungen und
anderen Werken ansehen, darunter über Mahabharata
, die Philosophinnen im
alten Indien porträtieren, also werden wir
Kulturen bewegen, aber nicht sehr weit und
Zeit  und das wird in der
nächsten Vorlesung sein, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören